[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talked about whatever you got to
get this full on the cafe blue oh dude
I'll play all your instruments Bravo
interlude and that'll be good I'll be
[ __ ] I'll rock that I'll rock the
pipes man
[ __ ] whatever you need cuz I gotta back
up this [ __ ] right here Mexican
style we could go [ __ ] traditional
like elementary school like upgrade your
flutes are in in hip-hop dobro yeah like
you've got you got a future with the
Buddha himself artists on the transit I
would trap beats like flute just works
you know anything works with the [ __ ]
trap yo what the [ __ ] it is you're
working on a new album yeah it's coming
out in like two weeks hopefully well
how'd you explain these people with
[ __ ] cafe blue is the cat blue and
Kato now first of all I'm not I'm not
mentioning cafe blue like it's a real
place it's an imaginary fantasy bar
because I don't want to ruin my bar that
already exists that exists but like the
whole idea of the project is like it's
more of like a bar or a place that like
you know everyone's welcome there's no
judgement we cheers like Doug magic
cheers but more like darker like be
dressed up in Hollywood yeah exactly
that's suppose that's what the vibe is
so the intro is like you come to this
bar and at the end of the project that's
like you're leaving you know I mean now
they are it was supposed to be an
imaginary bar until you [ __ ]
mentioned it I got Devon
blue B both French word cafe and blue
like Blair Blair Cafe is a French word
yeah Cafe blue TEP it's a small project
or it's Mexican Cafe F word oh yeah how
does that work is it it does that
typeset in Spanish or what axes that
they have it's French but Oh make it
being a music legit is on the album
cover is an app that's the cafe ice
innovative in these copies have joys of
the bikini yeah nobody knows about that
like the message we're just burning all
those BOTS right now you don't like
those those Vietnamese coffee shops like
they have they're supposed to black it
out the window is [ __ ] yeah but the
there was this vegan ice cream spot I
was going to and I walked by it was a
bit nummies coffee shop they did the
worst job ever
it was like a square here and then
another square 10 inches coffees genius
the point that's genius
we were like oh damn what's going on in
there I shouldn't want baby image fries
what I'm saying I literally just walked
by I was like oh and from the inside out
they see this weird ass dude following
the [ __ ] outline of the square it was
a part of poreotics indian type hagen
poreotics can came over over the weekend
he showed Isaac had to do like this
tutting thing it was so freaking hella
[ __ ] now I did oh my god that's why
kids dance though that's to talk to
women all the dancers only dance in high
school to talk to win yeah but I don't
know if tithing get super baby
I get your number your digits having to
be like the oddest thing because it's
just this dude like I make an imaginary
box yeah but you know like og tutting
like they would dance with it but this
is like getting a sick yeah I'm saying
like they would move but this one they
just stay right here yeah and they have
a [ __ ] camera and they just go up and
they'd start doing [ __ ] makes me laugh
dude so Isaac had a private dance class
yeah pretty much
so it was like for camp because cams
doing like his own personal challenge I
for every single day he wants to upload
a video of himself dancing on his
Instagram oh and then she's also doing
collabs with a lot of people like people
that don't usually dance creative man
yeah and so he did one with Isaac and he
came out so cute because it was like she
was doing like this stuff but not her
know what else yeah but it was really
cute in a second I miss them saying the
ladies are you ready Friday to start
open mouth kissing girls how the dirty
boy but I think I was like pie it was
close to action right like I would say
like 12 or something like what graders
tip yeah when I was when I was in fifth
grade I was like I can't wait till I'm a
man so I could [ __ ] slow kiss a girl
slow slow kiss I mean I don't really
know about sex
it was definitely sixth grade though
that you started getting a harmonium
yeah and then ah yeah I remember cuz I
was like I can't wait til I get older so
I could start rubbing my hard boner on
there
I don't know cuz you don't know sex you
just got a [ __ ] boner and then you're
like but dry hump the [ __ ] out of that
girl I remember when I was 10 and I
found out people are gonna hang out at
someone's house I'm like [ __ ] that's a
really long bike ride but I'll bike
anywhere to go there just because it
girls they're like three cities in
Cerritos I drove like I mean I wrote all
it's like Norwalk where she how old are
you like ten or eleven that's a good new
I was gonna go there and just even being
in the presence I'm like [ __ ] that was
like bust enough
definitely masturbate was about 12 years
old I think and I thought I found out a
secret I did that nobody had a good time
yesterday I can't tell you why let's go
play Bob like I think I'm staying in
today is your pee my colors different
let you know I'm telling you we had our
[ __ ] bar ball retreat and and it's
just it's just a retreat for the whole
company it is just bond and chill out
and have a good time
so I hired my nephew and he works at the
company he's 19 I've known this child
since he was born right so we were
playing this game it's only like 5 years
passed losing his virginity - all right
all right all right I don't wanna think
about it I hope he did we're playing two
truths 1 lie right so we're all going
we're playing this [ __ ] game and it
comes to him
I didn't hear everything thank God but
basically I understood that cops tapped
on his window because him and his
girlfriend were having sex in the
backseat now there's just like what in
the [ __ ] is happening right now like why
the [ __ ] are you having sex
well I thought you'd say why the [ __ ]
don't you have your windows tinted no I
just I am NOT I wasn't ready
I just wasn't like I knew but because
you see them born yes like you change
their diapers and then like now they're
heavy that's the part that I don't get
cuz like I think as a dad
the minute Tycho was born I know how I
was gonna freak even a [ __ ] boners
and me sex
I didn't use that the minute he was born
but we did you like don't you all
surprised when you're hurt you know if
you're the Freak no I wasn't thinking I
wanna if you can't avoid it then cool I
don't want to think about it like Timson
Isaac open-mouth kissing someone you're
like yeah I'm like I can already imagine
Titan awesome in the chick
Oh nasty because it's like you've seen
the drool you've smelled their [ __ ] like
that
this is hampering I know too much about
this child like you should have the
opposite I'm just like so judgy if I'm
like yeah kissed you haven't had sex yet
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you maybe
that I'm going but if it's your daughter
you know what that is yet I mean it
sucks that it's inevitable but I'd be
like [ __ ] I wouldn't want that to happen
like you know like I don't have that
future fear so it might be different
when I have a daughter but I don't I
don't have a future fear like I could
imagine I'm like yeah she gonna be a
home whatever I got my genes man what's
hard is like you you like you saw me she
was brand spanking new like she didn't
talk like you've invested all this time
you better not touch my inventory
basically and like we're not I think
it's more that you're in denial
the minute I see my daughter get born I
already know her baby vaginas at Palmer
one crazy you're telling me every single
down out there things exactly it's like
when you buy shoes you know that she's
gonna get crazy I think they do snot the
way I walk in a movie asleep being more
vulgar about it but like we all know all
of our kids are gonna have that in the
wording choice could have helped out a
little bit
baby [ __ ] getting pummeled vagina and
pummeled actually the whole sentence in
a bit
yes just get to learn I think a better
way to put it is like one day that baby
pussy's gonna turn into a mature old
brie like making but I can't dude you
didn't I I changed the image though at
least I made it grow before I follow you
so implants at the baby [ __ ] in maimana
well it exists it's not a Barbie doll
but don't put that image in my mind okay
well okay a [ __ ] Forbes it [ __ ] forms
and as a woman grows it opens up opens
oh they're born as a Barbie doll
with nothing there and then as they
mature and ready then it starts to open
like us anyone gonna tell us no I'm
doing it I'm making this up so then
it'll make things nicer for everybody
like period we do have to talk about
Arliss you feel like your lights you
like so for example my mom always told
me I came from her ass just like some
hole through my whole life I didn't even
know girls had a [ __ ] until my
next-door neighbor's daughter ran out
without a diaper on I'm like a little
slit in the front and I had to ask my
mom about that and she was like okay
I've been lying to you actually it came
out of my [ __ ] and that's why I
described things like that always
covered in [ __ ] when I was bored and I
had to be washed that's what I thought
too
no I mean I talked to Isaac about sex
and so I keep it open
what do you say give me the tongue I'm
Isaac give it to me well when it
wouldn't well it's Martin in baby steps
so when he was a little mommy were with
where did they come from
he never asked me I actually just told
him asking the right question of who's
not inquisitive no yeah I think I just
started with like ass of boys have
penises and girls has these things
called vaginas or finger tutting it's
like this shape
he's like magic do this ludus big [ __ ]
jazak you have a baby penis in the
nipple can as he's like this rabbit to
his kid he's doing a [ __ ] Cuddy set
as his dick Rises I guess the final
moves just approached him baby steps and
then now that he's older and now like
his he's about to have his body change
you know I'll talk about things were
fake yeah so you know I know you're
gonna want to eventually start playing
with yourself oh my god you said it tub
talk that introduce it to of like what
you could play with it you gotta do the
Korean parenting thing and just
completely shut the [ __ ] up and go to
your room dude I don't know dude this
like like educate about masturbating in
Sabac wow I can't be just like you guys
come everywhere figure it out it depends
on the kid I'm gonna tell my kid if
they're going to hell yeah we were like
I learn how to jack off from my friends
brothers and [ __ ] they're all talking
about yeah you just want you gotta talk
to your kids yeah and I'm gonna like I'm
on like what and then like we will all
watch porn and I'm like ooh this is nice
and they're like yeah man like everybody
Jack's off yeah you know what that is
right and I wanted to be cool so I'm
like yeah I was like I gotta find out
what this jackoff thing is all about
and I was like hey this feels good and
then like when you first nerd it's like
dry heaving it's like that's what you
think those
yeah it is but nothing comes out
sunbathing lizard but then you feel weak
and weird after like oh yes it feels
really weird and you gotta keep doing it
over and then like like clear fluid
comes out and then as you bring white
stuff comes out is it cuz it's crazy
yeah it would be my mind when you start
doing that before you at puberty yeah
there's not the no [ __ ] semen or
nothing produced yeah I was like fourth
or fifth grade get the gun with the bang
yeah my grandma had this [ __ ] neck
massager thing that I would wrap around
my dick and [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of Oh
[ __ ] bust all kinds of nuts in that
[ __ ] and it will just be slimy ass bug
covered in that [ __ ] [ __ ] garlic and
I'm like an eyeball that after would you
finally find out that masturbate wasn't
a secret that you found out about yeah
cuz all the people started talking about
it like around me yeah I mean we do it's
like it's when you first do it you're
just like you don't know how to react
you think you're doing something wrong
you don't know like what it is you know
I'm saying just like this is fire yeah I
mean you're young due to you get horny
for every little thing this kids like is
watching this they're just like drinking
off the dish it right now for no reason
yeah the source of any masturbation
right now but not this is Perot like
back and they go come on we watched TV
and Spanish news yo like don't till this
day nothing has changed is wild on e bt
uncut you know like we had
yeah catalog you know before even
internet like you know we're like a
little older so we this is like before
like DSL none of that [ __ ] we had all
the magazine spreads I'm being bathroom
having magazines like open ten magazines
open done that's like having different
tabs open from back there yeah it was
all tight was like my mom my mom
stocking like wrapper of one of her
things
like remember to old like swap meet
stuff yeah there's like a hot model with
a layer where it is [ __ ] like oh dude I
remember those days
that's desperation man Oh easy man now
it's like a loaded weapon like we got a
[ __ ] phone like kids could Jack at
cut anywhere they're having less sex now
it because they just jack too much not
well I heard it like it's because people
are like kids are so awkward now with
the way they interact with like girls
and boys because they're all do it
behind the Internet so just do it all
yeah yeah so they're all socially very
awkward when they see each other or meet
each other so they'd rather [ __ ] on
chatroulette balance there's balance in
the world then not like they really have
like a whole like the statistics like
it's like class it's crazy what are they
doing like beating off on chatroulette
and stuff like that no and then I think
that's more blogging all the creepy
person rather like Skype and [ __ ] like
no oh my kid to be socially awkward I
gotta get they gotta learn how to like
speak to people and [ __ ] just because
like yeah sometimes we see like a people
you know mind you like fans that that
come up to us like every now and then
but when you guys are socially lock that
really tell it you don't talk to people
at all you have no eye contact you're
stuttering over your stuff or you can
tend to say stuff that's like super
disrespectful and rude because you think
it's okay to chat format button gross
and it's [ __ ] weird like for example
we were at sip right and I was on my
phone I'll talk to my mom saying serious
conversation and this dude rolled up in
his car oh hey hey are you I was like
hey bro sorry man I'm on the phone real
quick I'm gonna milk serious talk with
my mom I'm like okay and he starts still
yelling at me I'm on the phone I'm on
the phone right now it's a serious
conversation
hey man it's nice to meet you right
you're the YouTube guy right hey what's
up I was like
oh I'm so sorry I was like [ __ ] veins
coming out and he just [ __ ] drove off
I went back to the for my mom's like
that was so bad who'd you the other but
it was like you know I was like being
super respectful I was like hey man
please like I'm a mysterious
conversation and he just kept on
screaming at me now that makes sense
that is real though they don't know how
to interact with people you know I'm
saying it's all internet like socially
awkward like there's a wall dividing
[ __ ] and I don't think there's enough
like social like social skills education
yeah you know saying like they should
have had that in school cuz so you know
like we all know social skills are so
important in like just real life [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's kind of weird how like
things change though because I remember
back in a day when we would do shows
like Asians were so [ __ ] quiet except
if you go to like Texas or the South
right they're like more rowdy or
Southeast Asians yeah but but now I feel
like Asian kids are a little bit more
outgoing and they actually scream at
shows and enjoy themselves and they know
how to like let loose but I remember
like back like eight years ago or
whatever every like the [ __ ] crowd
would be enjoying it but they're dead
[ __ ] quiet and he didn't know how to
let loose yeah I think we're still kind
of learning either that always just
sucked roll back to like back in the
days when you used to watch like these
like Korean concerts and it's just these
people in the crowd or the glow sticks
no facial expression South Korea it
looked like North Korea
[Music]